also i no longer entered the
rest room now
armed with my uncle adolphe and after
lingering around the back kitchen
when françoise appearing on the
forecourt told me i'm going to let my
wife my daughter two kitchens serve the
coffee and go upstairs  hot water
I have to save myself this plan has
mokhtar I decide to go back and
monthey directly read at home the
fidh kitchen was a legal person
a permanent institution acquired
invariable attributions ensure a
kind of continuity and identity
through  the fleeting succession of forms
in which s embodied because
we are never the same
two years in a row the year in which nine-year-old
james tend asparagus the
kitchen girl usually in charge of
plucking them was a poor creature in a bad state to
say  of pregnancy already
quite advanced that we arrived
capable and we were even surprised that
Françoise let her do so much
shopping and work because she was
beginning to lose weight.  rter with difficulty in front of
her the mysterious basket
more filled every day whose magnificent form we guessed under these
angles sarron
these recalled the or plande which
take on some of the
symbolic figures of giotto of which sir this
fans had given me the photographs
it is himself  who hadn't pointed it
out when they asked us
about the kitchen girl he
said and how is his charity from
giotto besides herself
the poor girl fattened by her
pregnancy up to the face until the
day which fell  straight and square
look indeed quite quite
strong virgin and matronly mas rather in
which the virtues are personified
at the arena and I realize
now that her padua virtues and
vices still look like her in
another way as well as  the image of
this girl was heightened by the
symbol added that she wore in front of her
belly without seeming to understand
its meaning it comes out that nothing from her vira
ge translated its beauty to the mind as a
simple and heavy burden, just as
it is without doubt that the
powerful housewives who represented at
the arena under the name caritas and
whose reproduction of the hung on the
walls of my dining room  the combret study
embodies this virtue it is undoubtedly a
thought of charity seems never to have
been expressed by her
energetic and vulgar face by a beautiful
invention of the painter she tramples
the treasures of the earth under foot but absolutely
as if she were cooking  grapes
to extract the juice as soon as possible as
she would have climbed on sacks to
raise herself she offers her heart in flames to god
and 10 take place they
pass it to him like a cook not that which
rouchon by the ventilator of her basement
someone who asks her at the
window on the ground
floor envies her she should have had more of a
certain expression in life but in
this fresco there again the symbol holds
so many places is represented  as if
real the snakes that hiss at the lips
of the envied so big they completely fill there
his wide-open mouth
that the muscles of his face are
stretched to be able to contain him
like those of a child who inflates a
balloon with his breath and that
the attention of the envy to another at the same
time entirely concentrated on
the action of his lips hardly has
time to give to the envious to think of himself
despite all the admiration that
this fan professed for his faces  of
giotto I had no pleasure for a long time in
considering our bosom of studies we had
hung up the copies that he had
brought me this charity without charity
this desire which looked like a
plate illustrating only in a
medical book  the compression of the
cigarette or the letter by a tumor of
the tongue or by the introduction of
the instrument of the operator a justice
whose grayish face and miss km in
regular was the very one who at
combret characterizes
certain pretty  well  pious and
dry urgeoise that I saw at mass and therefore
several is to enlist in advance in the
reserve militias of injustice but
later I understood that the
striking strangeness the special beauty its
frescoes gave to the great place that  the
symbol occupied there and that the fact that they
were presented not as a symbol
since the thought to symbolize is not
expressed but as real as
actually suffered or materially
handled gave the meaning of
the work something more literal
and  more precise in his teaching
something more concrete and the
most striking in the poor
kitchen girl too the tension was
not constantly brought back to her belly by
the weight which pulled it and even still
very often the thought of the dying
is turned towards the
visceral dark painful effective side towards this
reverse side of death which is precisely the
side which it represents and makes them
feel harshly and which looks a
lot like pl  us a burden that
crushes them a difficulty in breathing
a need to drink that this case what
we call the idea of death it was necessary t
at these cruel virtues of padua using me we
l of reality since they marc appear
as also  alive than
the pregnant servant and that she herself did
not seem to me much less
allegorical and perhaps this
non-participation, at least apparent, of
the soul of a being in the virtue which acts through
him has also outside of its value
aesthetic a reality if not
psychological at least as we say
physio that our munich times later
I had the opportunity to meet
during my life in convents for
example
truly holy incarnations of active charity
she generally had 1st cheerful a
indifferent and abrupt positive of
surgery after it is this face
bind no coloring no
tenderness in front of human suffering
no fear of alert and
who is the face without gentleness the face
anti  pathetic and sublime of the real
climb while a son of kitchen
making shine voluntarily has the
superiority of Françoise as the error
by the contrast makes more brilliant the
triumph of the truth
it will be coffee which according to mom was
only l  hot water and then rises
in our rooms hot water which
was barely lukewarm
I had stretched out on my bed a book
in hand in my room which
tremblingly protected its transparent
and fragile coolness against the sun of the
afternoon read rc shutter almost closed - reflection
of days had nevertheless found a way
to pass its wings
splendor of
light was given to me only by the
blows struck in the street of the cure by
camus warned by françoise that my aunt
was not resting that one could make
noise against dusty boxes
but q  ui resounding in the
special sound atmosphere or of a show seemed to
make scarlet stars fly away
and also by the flies which performed in
front of me in their little concert like
the chamber music of summer they
do not evoke it at all  the way of an air of
human music that you heard by chance in
the summer season then reminds you there
it is united to the summer by a more
necessary link nor the beautiful
days reread meaning only with them containing a
little of their essence
it does not come back only the image
in our memory it years certifies the
return the effective ambient presence
immediately accessible this dark
coolness of my room and is to the full
sun of the street what the shade is to the
radius
it is to  to say as luminous as he and
to the freight hamon esteems imagination the
total spectacle of helping him in my senses
if I had been on a walk could only have
enjoyed bit by bit is like this and
fits well with my rest which thanks
to the adventures  told p  ar my books
which came to move him support such
at rest an immobile hand in the middle
of running water
the shock and the animation of a torrent
of activity and my grandmother even if
the too hot weather had spoiled if  a
storm or only a squall had
arisen came to beg me to go out and
do not want to give up my reading
jallet at least there continue your gardens
under the chestnut tree in a small
sentry box in esparto and canvas at the back
of which I was seated thought I was
hid from the eyes of people who
might come to visit my
parents and my thought was also not
like another manger at the bottom of
which I felt that I was staying
buried even to watch what was
happening outside
when I saw an object outside the
awareness that I saw him remains
between me and him the thin spiritual edging brothel that prevented
me from ever
directly touching his way it
somehow vanishes
before I made contact with him.  ec it is like
an incandescent body that one
approaches a wet object does not touch its
humidity because it is always
preceded by an evaporation zone in
the kind of screen said after
different states that  while I read
simultaneously deploying my consciousness and that
they went from the deepest
cachia aspirations
to the vision from the outside of
the horizon that I had at the end of the garden
before my eyes what there was to  First
in the most intimate months the ever-shifting police
that ruled the
rest it was my belief in wealth
philosophy in beauty books that I
read and my desire to appropriate them
was stronger than before even though
I read them  I had bought a lot when I saw it in
front of the bord ange grocery store, too
far from the house for françoise
lucie to supply like at camus but
better stocked as an approved stationery
the early fronts of its mysterious door no
longer but to think that a
door of cathedrals is that
I had recognized it for having been cited to me
as a remarkable work by the
professor the comrade who
seemed to me at that time to hold the
secret  of the truth of beauty to denis
sensed to two but incomprehensible
whose knowledge was the vague
but permanent goal of thought